AND HAPPY NEW YEAR MEMBERS I
COMMITTEE IN THE PUBLIC WELCOME
TO THE SOMEBODY PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT
COMMITTEE WE HAVE ONE BILL ON
THE GENDER TODAY A. B. NINE
SEVEN I REYES AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CERVANTES WILL BE ABSENT
WITH THAT SECTOR LIKE CALDERON.
THE STEP SCORN. RODRIGUEZ HERE
VOEPEL CERVANTES COOLEY. COOPER
FONG YOUR O'DONNELL HERE. WE
HAVE ESTABLISHED A QUORUM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AS BUT- THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS TO
THEIR PRESENTING AB NINE SEVEN
NINE FIRST I WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE FOR AND
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL THE
WORK ON THIS BILL. EASILY
CALPERS AND AS CALLOUS TERRACE
WERE REQUIRED TO PROVIDE A FIVE
YEAR STRATEGIC PLAN FOR
EMERGING MANAGER PARTICIPATION
ACROSS ALL ASSET CLASSES. OTHER
INVESTMENTS AND TO SUBMIT AN
ANNUAL REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE REGARDING THE
PROGRESS OF THEIR STRATEGIC
PLANS THIS REQUIREMENT SUNSETS
IN THE CODE ON JANUARY FIRST.
OUR SUNSET DID JANUARY FIRST
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THIS BILL
PLACES BACK INTO LAW. THE
REQUIRED ANNUAL REPORTS TO THE
LEGISLATURE RECALL REGARDING
CALPERS AND CALLOUS TERRACE
USING. THE EMERGING MANAGERS
FOR PURPOSES OF ASSET
MANAGEMENT. WITH THE SUPPORT
YES YOUR TURN MEMBERS MIKE
FOLLOWED ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA JUDGES ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK.
ANY OTHERS THAT. SENIOR NONE
ARE ANY WITNESSES OPPOSITION TO
THIS MEASURE. SEEN HEARING ON
THE QUESTION BY TWENTY MEMBERS.
SEEN ON SOME REMEMBER AS LIKE
CLOTHES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. ARE WE NEED A
MOTION MOVED OUT OF THEIR
MOTION SICKNESS COOPER SIGNAL
BY MR FONG. WITHOUT TO I
RECOMMEND RECOMMEND AN AYE VOTE
THIS THE SAME BILLS ONE WHICH
PREVIOUSLY PASSED BY THIS
COMMITTEE LAST YEAR ON THE
SEVEN OH VOTE. SORRY DRUG AN
AYE VOTE AND SENATOR LIKE COLOR.
RODRIGUEZ AYE RODRIGUEZ AYE AND
VOEPEL CERVANTES. COOLEY AYE
COOLEY AYE COOPER AYE COOPER
AYE FONG AYE FONG AYE O'DONNELL
O'DONNELL NO. THE BILL HAS.
OTHER MEASURES UP THE
GOVERNMENT. AND MEMBERS WE ARE
JOURNAL THANK YOU ALL FOR
ATTENDING THANK YOU MEAN IS